and the coordinates of point P along the
directed line segment a B so that a P to
P B is in the ratio of 3 to 2 so what
this means is we're starting at a point
a we're heading towards point B but we
want the ratio of let's say point P is
somewhere in here okay we don't know
somewhere along this line but we want
that ratio here to be 3 to 2 so what
that means is you're heading
three-fifths of the distance from a to P
so I'm just gonna write that three
fifths of the way okay so I added these
together three parts out of five so what
I'm going to do here is I'm going to say
okay for X the x coordinate of point P
we're starting out at negative 2 for the
y coordinate we're starting out at 7 but
look what's happening we're gonna be
going down so much over so much so we're
going down 7 minus 2 which is 5 so we're
going down 5 ok
and we're going right 5 okay so down 5
and right 5 so this is going to affect
the y coordinate this is going to affect
the x coordinate so what I'm going to do
now is I'm going to the x coordinate I'm
going to add 3 fists remember 3 fifths
of this horizontal distance so three
fifths of five okay and for the Y I'm
going to add the wreath this of negative
5 since we're going down five so three
parts out of five out of negative five
so this is going to come out to three
minus 2 which is 1 these are going to
cross reduce that's going to give you
negative 3 plus 7 which is 4 so Point P
is going to be at 1 comma 4 so we're
going to be right 1 1 2 3 4 so it's
pretty close with my estimate here and
that's it so that's 3